allez on va parler rugby féminin à
présent samedi avait lieu la rencontre
entre la France et l'Angleterre
catégorie moins de 20 ans match qui
s'est soldé par une victoire des
Françaises 40 à 31 devant 5000
spectateurs dans quelques instants le
compte rendu complet dans votre JTD
sport mais d'abord le rugby féminin en
pleine expansion entourage se reportage
de Clémence d'OSC au club de
Joué-lès-Tours
valeureuse et en sororité le rugby
féminin se démocratise depuis quelques
années à l'US de jouer les tours elles
sont une centaine de joueuses soit un
bon tiers des effectifs du club
rejoindre par plusieurs équipes des
départements voisins les moins de 15 ans
se sont entraînés ensemble samedi
dernier chacune a ses raisons de
rejoindre l'équipe et beaucoup
s'accordent sur le manque de visibilité
des femmes dans le rugby et de la
perpétuation de certains clichés on voit
vite fait pour les six nations et vite
fait pour la Coupe du monde mais sinon
on en parle pas alors que le Top 14 pour
les gars c'est tout le temps à la télé
et tout on en parle tout le temps alors
que les filles sont imaginaires on a un
peu plus musclé parce que du coup on
court on plaque on force et je trouve ça
injuste qu'on nous dit ce qu'on est
grosse alors que ben on fait du rugby
quoi et c'est vrai qu'avec au stade de
jouer avec les filles qui dès que tu
tombes ou un truc comme ça elles sont là
pour trop lever elles sont là pour être
avec toi et du coup ça ça met de la
confiance parce que tu dis ok bon bah
c'est bon je peux le faire je suis assez
compétente pour faire ce sport des
rencontres amicales sur le terrain et
une formation rugby féminin pour les
encadrants la fédération est venue
présenter une mallette pédagogique des
ressources pour les entraînements qui
tiennent compte des spécificités des
joueuses et brise les tabous quand on
entraîne un public féminin quel que soit
le sport c'est important de prendre en
considération le cycle des joueuses pour
pouvoir justement les les amener à être
plus performantes les amener à évoluer
en toute sécurité à chaque fois ça a
surpris pas mal les les participants aux
différentes interventions mais pour moi
c'est indispensable c'est quelque chose
ça fait partie de la vie des femmes exit
l'idée d'un entraînement moins intense
il est ciblé sur les muscles et les
blessures sont les plus fréquentes chez
les femmes un suivi qui a pour but
d'améliorer les performances et de
fidéliser les jeunes adhérentes on a une
augmentation d'effectif qui est
considérable nous sommes aujourd'hui à
plus 17% de et on est aujourd'hui plus
fort même que les inscriptions garçons
cette fille viennent rejoindre le club
le plus proche pour pratiquer ce sport
et puis les petites filles elles ont
plus peur de faire le sport qu'il aurait
été interdit parce qu'il était masculin
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui ça
avance très très bien la Fédération
espère une hausse des effectifs via
l'effet Coupe du monde mais la mise en
lumière du rugby passe aussi par des
événements locaux à l'image de la
rencontre France Angleterre samedi
dernier